hey everyone
so this has been a really interesting
week uh because for the first time in
like 14 years of playing classical
guitar i
am playing without nails and for me this
is
a radical change um basically what
happened was
i was finding my nails shorter and
shorter and discovering that
by mixing a bit of nail and a bit of
flesh into my sound
on each pluck i could get this warmer
tone and i kind of realized as i was
filing at some point
that when i was plucking i was getting
this nice
warm sound but actually i wasn't even
touching the nail anymore
so that's no nail playing uh and so
anyway i've been spending a week
it's only been about a week messing
around with no nail playing and figuring
out how it works and
what are the advantages and
disadvantages so today i thought it'd be
really fun to share with you
how i think no nail playing sort of
works from what i can tell so far
as well as a bit of the history of no
nail playing on classical guitar
and at the end i'm even going to try to
do a bit of a comparison
when i play some pieces with nails and
some pieces without
and we can we can hear the difference
so while it's true that today most
classical guitarists
sense segovia and maybe even partially
due to segovia's influence
play the classical guitar with nails
this wasn't always the case
before segovia and maybe you could say
before world war
ii um when gut strings were the
standard string we know of a long
history of guitar playing where
some guitarists played with nails and
some guitarists didn't
even into the 19th century when you get
the sixth single string guitar
some players like sore karkaze targa
famously didn't play with nails in fact
soar
even has this really interesting quote
he says never in my life
have i heard a guitarist whose playing
was supportable if he played with the
nails
their performance is to mine what the
harpsichord was in comparison
to a piano forte and in karkaze's method
book
he says something similar to obtain a
full and mellow tone
apply some force at the top of the
fingers but avoid touching the strings
with the nails
except for special effects but of course
at the same time
you have guitarists like aguado who
prefer the nails
although it's worth pointing out that
apparently later in life
sore actually convinced aguado to
cut off his thumbnail so he played just
with the flesh and the thumb
and apparently he even says that if he
was to go back and do it all again he'd
play with flesh
all right now before we start playing i
just want to read you one more quote to
get us started
by emilio pejol who actually was a
student of targas
who at the end of his life started
playing without nails
and so did therefore so did pujol he
says that
since the fingernail is hard and varied
in its surface
thickness and consistency it imparts to
the string a
penetrating brilliance quick and
rather metallic without nails however
the string is struck by a smooth
subtle and sensitive object both thicker
and wider than the nail
and which gives a sound of greater
softness fullness
and purity and i have to say that after
a week of playing without nails
that quote summed up my experience
perfectly
so let's finally play and let's see what
we're talking about here
on my thumb i still have a normal nail
and that's because when i play with
flesh i actually play
uh lower on the thumb and the nail
doesn't get in the way so i can have
both
so this is actually the perfect way to
demonstrate i think let's hear some nail
playing on the first string
[Music]
so the string starts in the pocket which
is the space
in between the flesh and the nail the
little v shaped
pocket down there but it's definitely
making contact
with the nail when i'm touching the
string and then when i release
the string the the string takes a ride
on the on the ramp of the nail you could
say and i think pujol is right i mean
it has a penetrating brilliance to it
and i really think that's the sound that
i've come to love
about the classical guitar okay now
let's hear the flesh of the thumb
[Music]
a much more dark mellow tone
but still resonant and it's so resonant
because i'm making a point of pushing
the string down
to the top of the guitar towards the top
if i was to just pluck the string
horizontally like i do kind of by nail
it's a very thin sound so i think with
flesh you have to sort of push
the string down more but if you do you
get a
very resonant beautiful tone and i think
what i figured out is that
that's exactly what you have to do with
all the fingers is you grab
on the flesh first and then
you push the string down towards the top
of the guitar
and let go and then wow a beautiful
resonant warm
[Music]
[Music]
tone
for me it also really helps to touch the
string on the flesh
push down and let the the tip joint
collapse
um if you do that and then
release letting the finger follow
towards the palm
follow through towards the palm kind of
like sore says a pluck
is just closing your hand one finger at
a time right
[Music]
so i took all those principles of
pushing the string down and grabbing on
the flesh not the nail
and i applied them to some guitar
repertoire and it sounded like this
[Music]
it's a super warm intimate sound
which i really am growing to love and
then i made a really interesting
discovery
i realized when i was teaching a guitar
lesson that i could still play on my
nails because
my nails actually grow really close to
the tip so even though
it looks like i don't really have any
nail i can still play with it if i want
to so if i angle correctly
that's nailed of course the thumbnail is
easy because i still have a long
thumbnail
but with the fingers if i just careful
about making contact
with the nails
no problem it's a little bit tricky for
me obviously with a slightly longer nail
i think i don't have to work as hard so
maybe this isn't my best nail tone but i
can do both
which then led me to think let's make a
video where i
show you a and b flesh and nail let's
see how it sounds and to do this test
i'm going to use
this really lovely guitar by sayrs
guitars
this is a torres copy flame maple
back inside spruce top tourist guitars
are what
targa played and so i thought this would
be appropriate to use
currently i have it strong in nile gut
but i have just ordered some gut strings
so stay tuned for another video about
that
so speaking of targa let's try a little
bit of lagrama
with nail and then on the repeat without
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so it's definitely darker and more
mellow with flesh
i think i'm really noticing in the base
especially i mean
that's nail and then
[Music]
the flesh so there's just more high
partials you could say
high overtones with the nail let's try a
piece by fernando soare who is a big
proponent of
no nail playing
[Music]
oh i really like it on that one that
darker sound seems to really complement
that now they call it key of b minor
let's try another piece by soar
this is the introduction to his
variations on a theme by
[Music]
mozart
[Music]
[Music]
wow that one's really interesting
because i know this piece really well
i've played it for a long time with
nails
and there are some aspects that i'm
loving about the flesh with it
and others which i kind of you know
prefer the nails
for example one of my favorite effects
is playing super super quiet
like a choir from a mile away where you
play very quiet
[Music]
but because of the nail it's still
very clear
[Music]
with flesh
it's a little bit less focused but
really resonant so i like the resonance
but i don't like the lack of focus i
think
but okay there's one more piece i want
to try i'm a little afraid of this one
people are always commenting on my
tremolo videos can i do this without
nails
and um well let's find out
[Music]
okay so it's possible i find it a bit
difficult
um i think i actually might need even
less snail than i have now
to really pull that one off so i already
have a lot of takeaways here from
this experiment the first one is
i'm definitely not experienced enough
with no nail playing um
i think there are things that i'm slowly
realizing about this technique
which i need a lot of hours put in to
really develop this technique to its
full potential and
always have a full tone for example
the one thing that i think is the
hardest for me so far is remembering to
always push
the string down manually because i think
with nails especially with a ramp shape
nail which i usually have when i have
long nails
i think what's happening is that the
nail really does a lot of the work
pushing the string down towards the top
of the instrument
which is what gives you a lot of
resonance
but when you take the nail off if you
don't push the string down
you don't get the resonance so you have
to make up for it
by actively pushing it down with the
weight of the the arm
so that's some homework for me but in
short
i'll say that in terms of the pros and
the cons here
the pros of playing with flesh to me as
i can tell so far
are that the tone is so resonant
and warm and rewarding
that i i just love the sound i think the
tone is absolutely beautiful
then i'm really loving the fact that i
can
make contact with the string
on a bigger surface on a soft surface
where i can really feel
and caress the string i feel like i'm
more in touch
with making the sound whereas when i
play with nail
i thought i was feeling that but it's
definitely compared to the flesh
less or so so i definitely feel more in
contact with the string
another big pro is of course i don't
have to worry about breaking a nail
this was a serious daily fear of mine is
breaking a nail right before a concert
that's it's no fun uh so no
nail maintenance uh no files no
sandpaper any nothing like that
and then i have to say that something
i'm missing about playing with nails
um is sort of the ease of playing
right um i know i'm new to the no nail
thing
and i have some time to put in here but
it seems to me that
when you play fast things like uh quick
arpeggios
or tremolo
that something about playing with nail
allows you to move
faster and still get that resonant sound
whereas i find myself a bit
uh sluggish with no nail playing
and the last thing i was thinking about
with playing without nails is that
you know in terms of the full spectrum
of timbre that's possible
on a guitar from super dark sounds to
super bright sounds
um when you play with nails i think you
get access
to those very very bright super high
overtones
but with flesh you kind of max out you
know
even if you play on the bridge with
[Music]
flesh
it doesn't sound that bright i mean
listen to nails
it's super super brassy you know of
course it's taste of when you want to
use that color but
the fact that it's hard to make that
color without using the nail
maybe is a disadvantage but then again
maybe that's what soar
and karkaze are talking about in terms
of special effects
they say they can use nails by curling
the finger more and imitating
an oboe i believe it is uh and i mean i
can do it right now
play with flesh and then with nail so
maybe that's the special effect
that soar is talking about okay that is
it for today
but stay tuned because when my gut
strings arrive i'm going to throw those
on
and we're going to try no nail playing
with gut strings
with some music by soar for example and
we'll we'll see how that how that sounds
if you're interested in going deeper
with the whole no-nail classical guitar
thing
i strongly suggest you check out rob
mckillip
on youtube i'll throw a link in the
description to his channel
he's got some fantastic videos which
really helped me
understand to a greater extent this
technique and he's got such a good
channel playing
all things that go pluck so check that
out and i hope you found this
[Music]
useful
you